[Musique]
retrouvez allons nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission ou somme soit
découvre la réunion semble vous allez
parler alors à
l'onu
c'est même mieux
pas moi
alors du coup ça mille et mille de la
commune de saint-leu mal à l'aise dans
l'auto sur le parking de kélonia alors
ousanousava nounou va aller jusqu'à la
pointe au sel plus précisément au musée
du sel alors là pas de sel son gardien
il est au bout là bas eh bien nous nous
ça va aller allons-nous
coincés en france rien que ça même les
dimanches
si l'on retrouve mon moment
rien là même aux cadets
[Musique]
le nom
comme si la nature ne connaît à la barre
il nous reste à
oh
bonjour messieurs bonjour comment allez
vous mais je vais bien lire ça bien
alors dites moi qu'est ce que vous
faites à aujourd'hui et la joie de
marche quotidienne comme tous les jours
je veux pas un instant mon épouse elle
fait de l'aquagym dans la gorge ab c'est
bien comme ça tu me fais du sport tout
le monde fait du sport à la famille et
pourquoi faire de la marche ici
précisément mais déjà parce que je vis
de saint leu deuxièmement donc j'évite à
piton c'est facile pour descendre
d'accord ici c'est vachement agréable
parce que c'est quand et surtout c'est
ombragé été comme hiver on peut marcher
même quand il fait très chaud et ça
c'est l'avantagé très agro avant
l'arrivée sur le bruit de la mer alors
est-ce que vous avez déjà été au musée
du sel oui alors quelques temps c'est
vrai alors moi je dois y aller est ce
que c'est bien ah oui non c'est très
bien c'est très instructif c'est très
bien puis en plus on peut ramener de la
fleur de sel qui est très bonne
au déballage voilà qui est à la plage
ponyo voit le four mais radicaux
conseils et l'appui aux histoires en
1953 c'est pierre mairat les camps qui
rachète l'usiné son frère raphaël et
laly décide de relance la production de
la chaux et de remettre lusine sur pied
il fallait aussi la matière première la
matière promesses et les coraux et le
bois
lusine l'arrêt fonctionner en 1995 et
les devient monument historique en 1996
tout allait bien agréable à la pompe
écosse ça serait bien ah bah tiens voilà
une petite famille comme ça soit banon
qui fait quoi à peine bonjour bonjour
oui mais là doucement au teint basané
bien sûr que ça me pique nique pour mon
anniversaire nous fasse mais 48 ans
belle occasion mais c'est le bureau de
mme bhutto et à voir la mer l'endroit
mais jouer et passer un bon moment alors
il a mangé
du gigot d'agneau c'est très bon c'était
trèbes badens hausse
portée par tout cas tu es bien gaia et
ben loulou continue jusqu'au musée du
sel à l'est
le papa de saint leu sans pales de temps
tu justement talentueux juste devant
kélonia et il paraît que maintenant tu
femelles il n'y avait pas à quoi des
milliers de kilomètres pour une épaule
au même endroit où il est né tout cela
grâce à bond de 2 qu'elle va reconnaître
notamment nous apprécient le velouté de
bodmer le l'ariane patates à durand ou
le manioc du bord de mer
au pays comment
la réunion s'amène miyem valbonne
ap le respect pour mon pays il vraiment
après depuis son lit
goût de la dame a dit renvoi de mon pays
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour monsieur comme les
savants et bien bas denver est là mais
la mort a prouvé samedi soir prochain
plus même si vous faites du roulant mais
l'épée faut réformer mais ça passe enjoy
d'accord il se passionna et oui c'est
mon par chobo et deuxième c1 après moi
d'accord est ce que dans le quartier
s'est lui-même et non plus tous ces
reports et boivin péché conseil d'état a
fêté la bagarre et trompait toutefois
saut à bas coût et bien trempé car on
avait toutefois sur le fait toutefois
son but du revenant dans l'eau de ce
côté là d'un des familles en temps par
un bond de bonne famille à cuba et déjà
- il parlait un peu aidé à mater à base
de poisson les 300 chevaux au hockey
diament annie doit aller vers le musée
du sel est ce que la ville est sur la
bonne route l'a8 est sur la bonne route
à l'info continue et accueille jusqu'à
la voix d abord s il fait la liste un
peu d'accord a commenté aller voilà
merci à toi mais
voilà nous arrive à la fin du sentier et
nous ça arrive au musée du sel alors ça
va être sans le savoir c'est que tous
les ans nana la nuit des musées et c'est
très bien c'est que les gratuits donc
c'est l'occasion à l'effet un cari
bonjour monsieur bonjour moi les ça va
bien venu au musée du sel bien sûr la
pointe au sel ben azzouz les sur un
espace naturel sensible de la réunion
qui appartient au conservatoire du
littoral le musée du sel est géré par le
département de la réunion et la
production de sel à l'extérieur faut
savoir que la peau de celles ben il
produit toujours de cette phase aller
assuré par la spa l'éden donc les seuls
saunier à la réunion dans son hifi
produits de sel et n'a que 6 à l'île de
la réunion est banale et là et d'amuser
la course a depuis trouvé alors alors le
musée a été inauguré en 2007 comme angel
ouais et en 2000
21 eh bien nous l'a inauguré une
nouvelle exposition permanente oui et
donc il n'ya pas elle celle ci ra shingo
c'est en fait une invitation à un voyage
dans l'océan indien sur les îles de
l'océan indien pour découvrir d'autres
sites de production de techniques de
production et aussi découvrir
toutes les traditions toutes les
cultures toutes la culture toutes les
croyances au toit du sel et noah soleil
tape ça et là et ça c'est un indice
important mais voilà au profit de celle
en fait de quoi leurs besoins a besoin
de l'eau de mer maintenant je le mets
salés nous on a besoin beaucoup de
soleil et un petit peu devant faut
savoir qu'ici nous exploite l'une des
zones les plus à l'est au monde 1 la mer
morte c'est la mer plus à l'est est
juste après il y en a pour tous l otan
avec un taux de salinité le 42 grand
paris
c'est en tout cas le petit malade sur le
littoral le salut tu es bien gaye a
aujourd'hui donné à beaucoup de jeunes à
la houle elle est vraiment magnifique
côté à la réunion les gaillards à l'on
prend le temps vise italie et poussa
rendez vous un prochain épisode de
l'émission allons-nous cette fois ci me
sera dans la commune de saint-benoît et
nous sera sur le sentier annales gagné 1
semaine la retrouve
je voulais la même
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présentée par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]